welcome back to New rockstars I'm Winnie
van laningham and black panther wakanda
forever is finally out on Disney plus
watching it up close and personal in
your living room gives us the
opportunity to scour every single detail
including the intricacies of Ruth E
Carter's afrofuturistic costume designs
listening to her recent interview with
Tana hessy coats on the Black Panther
wakanda forever official podcast
revealed tons of interesting behind the
scene looks at the way Carter expertly
put wakandan and telecommiel wardrobes
together and what it means for the
characters who wore them so today I'm
breaking down some costume details you
might have missed in wakanda forever if
you don't know Ruthie Carter she has an
incredible artistic accomplishments not
only has she worked on costuming for
over 40 films in series she was also the
first African-American and the first
black woman to win an Oscar for her
beautiful costume designs in the first
black panther she's truly the definition
of a genius at her craft mastering the
look of multiple periods and genres in
her designs including the
afro-futuristic aesthetic of Black
Panther and wakanda forever creating
costumes for wakanda forever was much
more challenging than it was for the
first BP film there were the obvious
reasons like the grief felt by the
entire crew in the wake of Chadwick
boseman's death but practicality also
required Carter to rethink many of her
original wakandan designs there are a
lot of water scenes in wakanda forever
and this presented a unique hurdle as
clothing and other accessories look and
behave much differently underwater she
said this about the experience on the
bpwf official podcast we had to rethink
everything for the wakandans the battles
and wakanda had to actually be made so
that they could get wet and they were
originally not made that way we made
them with Raffia and leather which does
not stand in the water so there was a
lot of thought process about how and
when embaku jumps into the water how
how's he going to swim in that costume
taking care of yourself is important so
good thing geology makes it easy to do
theology is a 16-time award-winning
personalized skincare company recognized
in hypebeast birdie Men's Health Esquire
and ask men grooming Awards with over 6
000 5 Star reviews just take a quick 30
second diagnostic quiz and geology will
create a simple and effective skin care
or hair care routine customized just for
you with ingredients that are
dermatologist tested proven to work and
personalized to your needs for Hair Care
geology's got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hair of your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products you wash your
hair less and save money more they also
offer body washes and deodorants that
are free of harsh ingredients and smell
great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
darker puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
their daily personalized skincare
routine comes with two face washes
morning face cream retinol night cream
and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only fifteen dollars if
you use code rockstar70 at checkout
that's over a hundred and fifty dollars
of product for just 15 bucks on top of
that you can take an additional 30 bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair or body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started just click the link in the
description according to another
interview with Indie wire Carter
explained that the door milage costumes
had to be completely redesigned from
their first version from bp1 to function
aesthetically and practically in the
water she said quote we had to start
from scratch because the Dora costumes
were made from leather and Beads so we
remade them with silicone rubber
basically flowier costumes also had to
be weighted to ensure they moved
properly on camera and articles or
accessories that needed to appear to
float had to be Tethered to achieve that
effect as for the Jabari tribe those
guys incorporate a lot of fur into their
outfits due to the cold climate in their
Mountain blinds no one quiet I knew how
fur would react when it got dunked and
it took several experiments to find the
right kind she also said quote we had to
test that costume in a 20-foot tank to
see what the hell this fur was going to
do in the water we had to go with all
kinds of synthetic fur and dip it in
water sometimes just a glass of water to
see how it would respond then there was
the issue of water damage certain fabric
she used in her designs after creating
several different looks for the
telekineal she realized that the dye
would run after being removed from the
water and added elements like chlorine
or salt would cause discolorations after
multiple takes certain materials would
fade or alter and had to be accounted
for during filming when it came time to
create costumes for the telekineal
Carter spent countless hours of research
on Mesoamerican culture and Aesthetics
to make outfits and accessories as
historically accurate as possible within
the afro-futuristic world of wakanda
creating a new world of latinx futurism
alongside it as a woman of color Carter
knows all too well what it's like to
have black cultures misinterpreted or
misrepresented in media and wanted to
ensure that everything she made for
wakanda forever was accurate graceful
and precise I want to go back to what
you said before which is now you're
bringing in a whole other culture and
I'm sure you have seen folks
get black cultural black guy sport
culture are wrong
many many many times
well we did develop another road map you
know our own set of files and research
on mesoamerica and the moment the second
the minute that we were connected with a
historian we started showing them all
the stuff we had everything that we had
to just get the first layer sorted out
because I know through black culture and
things that you see in paintings can
sometimes be manipulated so that it
shows up one side a one-sided view of
things and they actually eliminated
quite a lot of the images that we had
wow oh yeah they were like this is Aztec
it's not Mayan this is paintings that
were done by the Spaniards that wanted
to show the Mayans were inferior this is
a cornfield that would not have existed
as one of the very first superheroes in
Marvel history Neymar's first on-screen
appearance had to stand out Carter
worked tirelessly to root his character
design in Mayan culture including his
dual-headed feathered serpent neck piece
the two serpents are open mouths with a
large Pearl in the center which Carter
told the bpwf official podcast
represents water pearls are also often
used as a symbol of wisdom game through
experience which coincides with Neymar's
history and life story perfectly as a
child he learned to distrust colonizers
and Outsiders from the treatment of his
mother and his ancestors which
influenced the way he protected telecon
from the rest of the world according to
Carter she and Ryan coogler grappled a
little bit on whether or not the neck
piece should include the pearls but in
the end they decided to go with the
design it was also inspired by the
chitsunitsun Koko Khan pyramid which
features The Feathered Serpent God on
both sides of its staircase namor's
feathered headdress like the rest of the
water costumes also had to be tested
several different times with different
materials to ensure it maintained its
authenticity underwater they ended up
crafting several different versions of
it for land and sea the ladder made of
silicone and hey since the lions are
credited with the invention of rubber
using alternate textures to accentuate
his clothing and accessories was
technically historically accurate too
other accessories of name Wars like his
Jade ear spools were inspired by both
Mayan culture and natural elements Under
the Sea like kelp leaves fish fins or
bones she said quote we really dived
into whatever there was available to use
including what we felt that they would
have made or acquired from their
relationship with their distant cousins
on land Carter also faced the somber
task of honoring Chadwick Boseman and
King t'challa's memory in the clothes
worn at his wakandan funeral grief and
loss informed her wardrobe choices
deciding to dress the wakandan people in
white as a celebration of The Black
Panther's life in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly she expressed her
initial intimidation towards creating
all white clothing that still
represented the unique identities of
each African region in wakanda
experimenting with texture and tone
Carter even silk screened off-white
paint onto pure white fabric ultimately
Pure White was used most often in these
designs to honor Ghana's tradition of
wearing all white in morning raimonda's
funeral dress featured in the Bella
South African symbols all over it and
shuri's white Hood was inspired by a 3D
printed runway show that Carter attended
in Rome I just had to have that so we
created this costume hooded Cape but
also we printed what represented the
heart-shaped herb on the cake likewise
Queen raimonda also had a 3D printed
accessory her is a cholo a traditional
hand woven South African headpiece worn
by married women and with wakanda's
advanced technology why wouldn't they
have coalass 3D printed fashion for the
rest of Queen raimonda's costume designs
it was important for Carter to give her
a look for this movie that evoked her
new position of power as opposed to her
costume in the first black panther
interestingly the costume design for her
opening address to the UN was originally
made for a different scene with Angela
opening at the U.N is a totally
different energy to how she opened black
panther one she did have her crown and
her shoulder mantle and bp1 it was a
softer color she was she was you know in
a traditional look ready for the king's
Ascension challenge at the Warrior Falls
so this time she is the ruler of wakanda
and I felt like I had done five movies
with Angela and her arms have always
been Unforgettable
[Laughter]
and Ryan really wanted her to make a big
statement in this scene I believe this
costume that she has on in the U.N was
actually designed for another scene in
my mind and he selected that for the UN
sure he's clothing was also designed to
showcase the heaviness she felt in the
aftermath of her brother's death she and
Ryan decided to go with simple gray
outfits throughout the film to evoke the
feeling of Fading Into grease in both
the opening scene where she tries in
vain to save t'challa's life and the
scene where she takes the heart-shaped
herb to become wakanda's new protector
she's wearing muted gray these are just
some of the behind scenes facts that I
found most interesting we all should
really go check out the podcast for
yourself the lovely and talented Jessica
Clemons also has a video where she goes
way more in depth about this stuff so
please watch her vid next follow me on
Instagram and Twitter whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]